José Raúl Molino next President of Panama.
The poll published by the press today puts him at 26% he was at 1.
6 by 100 last time and now he has risen to 26 at 19% There are
those who still do not know who he is going to vote for and then
he follows with 10% Torrijos eh Ricardo Lomana and Rómulo rucs
and the others Here you can see him in the list and he will have
helped everything It is said that he was not invited to the debates.
The disqualification of Ricardo Martinelli
that will have made people decide on Mr. Molín?
Well,
obviously it is an issue that the victimization being made
by the followers of Ricardo Martínez and himself in Granada
is Ricardo Martínez in relation to whether he is guilty or not,
whether this is political persecution or not,
has now made him mill to take that amount of popular support.
They are believing that really because of their hatred of the PRD they
think that really well molino is the option gentlemen one thing is to
hate the PRD and reject outright the PRD government and another is to
forget all the government of this gentleman everything he has done and
everything he said and gentlemen molino is not
Martinelli are two different people.
But well at the end of the day I think that this is this screenshot
that I have a photograph of the Momento does not mean that it will be so.
May 5 Surveys have been all my life and even the one
that mimito went to the head and suddenly not even
martínel himself did not understand why it did not come out.
So this is a long way from May 5th?
But I see something interesting here that 19
percent who still don't know what he's going to do eh?
It's still strong eh?
There is room for the other candidates who have more chances to
explain Tomorrow there is a debate in Chiriqui to explain their
proposals and convince Because not only say I am going to give
employment I am going to give water I am going I am going the
yo-yo I am not interested I am interested in how they are going to do it,
just like most Panamanians who have not yet decided.
So well José Raúl Molino and r.
M are you celebrating today?
They are dancing and jumping on one foot.
But gentlemen,
there are many people who do not know who they
are going to vote for and anything can happen.
Leave me below what do you think of all this?
and here is the data sheet so that you don't say
later that you are making it up in the surveys.
Here is the data sheet.